the first thing that struck me about
google when i joined the company it was
very different in the sense that it was
a very optimistic place so it was a rare
place in which if you walk the hallways
and you spoke to people and you had
ideas people expanded on them you know
most of the times people try to tell you
why things won't work
i felt the spirit was different you know
people would tell you oh that's a great
idea you could do it this way and it
would be better so that struck me that
optimism
the fact that you can innovate make
things better solve problems
i think i think this is a spirit i've
tried to carry
now and it takes a lot of hard work
uh you have to encourage innovation
uh you know one of the counter-intuitive
things is companies become more
conservative as they grow
you have a lot more cash you have a lot
more resources but you know companies
tend to become more conservative in
their decision making
and so encouraging the company to take
risks and innovate and be okay with
failure and and reward effort not
outcomes
and that's very hard to do in an
organization people tend to reward
outcomes a lot of scaling up is about
making sure you preserve
the good things you had in the early
days and that gets harder as the company
becomes bigger you have to work harder
at it
but i think a big part of what we try
hard to do is keep that
culture of uh innovating with technology
building products
shipping things and you know and so that
that's one of the many things